chapter 11 is on the idea of a matrix
inverse so the first thing we're going
to do is look
it's a bit more complicated with
matrices for numbers of course the
inverse is simply one over the number
so the inverse of two is a half we'll
see what we're going to be looking at in
this
in this chapter uh is an analog of that
for matrices
it's it is uh in fact much more
complicated and we'll start with the
fact that there's
a notion of both a left and a right
inverse
okay so just to give you a rough idea i
mean
just to the setting is if i have a
number x
and it satisfies xa equals one that just
means the product of
it and another number a is 1. then
it's called the inverse and of course we
just write it as 1 over a
and that exists only if a is not equal
to 0. because if a is 0
there's certainly no number x for which
xa equals one because no matter what x
you choose
x a is zero um and of course it's the
only one i mean there's there's
there's only one inverse of two and it's
one half
now by analogy we'll say that a matrix x
that satisfies x a
equals i and notice that's the matrix
analog of this scalar equation here
um we're going to call that a left
inverse and it's left because
x operates on the left of a we'll see
also that there's going to be a right
inverse where x operates on the right
of a and for matrices they're different
and of course as you know
there's it doesn't commute matrix
multiplication is not commutative
so they're different things okay so so
if you have a matrix
on the that that mult when you multiply
uh on the left
uh by this matrix x uh then times a and
you get i
that's called a left inverse and
if a left inverse exists for a matrix a
we say it's left invertible so it means
so left invertible just means there is a
left inverse so here's an example here's
a matrix a
it is three by two um and
you can check i'm not going to do it but
here are two different left inverses so
already things are getting very weird
because you can multiply you can check
that b
a is i and also c a
is i i'm not going to do that but you
can check
that things are already weird right
because for a number
when there's an inverse there's only one
of them no such thing as being
two different numbers that when you
multiply by two you get one
okay so things are already a little bit
strange here
now it's related the idea of left
inverses and things
is related to column independence let's
see how that is so
the first claim is if if if a matrix a
has a left inverse c
then its columns are linearly
independent
okay now let's check that um
well to check that its columns are
linearly independent we'll
we'll we'll write down the matrix
equation ax equals 0. now what that
means is
that ax is one interpretation of it is
it's a linear combination of the columns
of a
with coefficients x i and then of course
what we'd like to show if if they're in
linearly independent we want to show
that the only way this can happen is if
x equals 0.
and suppose c a equals i that means that
a has a left inverse
c or a is left invertible well in that
case we'll just do some matrix
calculations here
of course if you multiply any matrix c
by the zero vector
you get the zero vector of potentially
different sizes
but here a x is zero so i'm going to
plug in
c times a x and i'm going to use the
fact that i can reassociate
a triple product any way i like and in
the first case i multiply a and x
together first then multiplied by c i'll
switch that by first multiplying c
and a ah but c a is the identity so
that's i
x and now we use the fact the identity
matrix times x is
x and you know i think i said this
before but the identity you should think
of as a matrix generalization of
the number one okay um
and if you look at this whole chain it
says x equals zero and so what we've
shown is the following
if ax equals 0 then x equals 0 and that
means that the only linear combination
of the columns of a
which gives you 0 is the one with 0
coefficients and that means the columns
are linearly independent so
what that says is if you have a left
inverse then your columns are linearly
independent okay now later in the class
uh not that much later actually we're
going to see
that a matrix is left invertible if and
only if
its columns are linearly independent in
other words if its columns are linearly
independent
it has a left inverse and we'll we'll be
able to construct one
we'll be able to show you how to do that
um
and that's this is the matrix
generalization of the following a number
is invertible
if and only if it is non-zero okay
uh then so what we can say is a matrix
is left in
left invertible if it only if its
columns are linearly
independent right so so here linear
independence
is serving as sort of an analog of being
non-zero
okay of course they're very different
things a matrix can be non-zero
but have dependent columns right so
these are different concepts but it's
the correct matrix analog
so this tells us immediately that if a
matrix is
um is left invertible it has to be tall
or square why because if it were wide
which means it has more columns than it
has
rows that would mean that would the
columns are automatically
the columns are immediately dependent
and therefore you cannot have a left
inverse
okay so let's see that you know that we
can solve linear equations
with a left inverse so suppose ax equals
b that's a system of linear equations
i'm not assuming it's square
uh wide tall anything okay well i will
immediately
so a has a left inverse c that tells you
actually
that that means that of course uh a is
taller squared
um then we do this we see that c
b is c and b is of course
a x i mean if x satisfies ax equals b
but c a is again the identity and that's
x and what we see
is something very cool um if you
multiply uh the right hand side b uh
by a left inverse you get a solution of
a set of linear equations
right so so that's and that's exactly
like uh let's write down the analog of
this for
uh scalars right you write a x equals
b and then we would write it uh
something like this we'd say well in
that case
x equals 1 over a times
b is actually a solution so here the
number 1 over a
is well it's the inverse of a but we can
think of it also if you like
as a left inverse of a and so that's
that's what this tells you here so
here this says that that if you multiply
by c which is this left inverse
you get a solution so so left inverses
at least are quite useful because they
allow you
a left inverse allows you to solve a set
of linear equations
now later we're going to find out
actually how to compute a left inverse
but for now we just observed that if you
have a left inverse you can solve linear
equations and that's useful
let's look at an example so here's a
it's a three by two
matrix here's b it's a three vector
and we have over determined equations ax
equals b it's over to determine because
there's essentially three equations and
two unknowns that's how you might say it
in sort of the high school language
and uh and it has the unique solution
uh there's only one solution of it and
it's one minus one okay
so they has two different left inverses
we already saw that it's the same one we
saw before here's b
and here's c and by the way when you're
talking about two different inverses
you're definitely outside the scalar
setting right because
numbers only have one inverse but
matrices can have several left
we'll see we'll see exactly what happens
but they can have
multiple left inverses now if you
multiply
the right hand side that's this b by
either b
or c in both cases you get the same
you get the same x and the reason is in
fact
that this set of equations has only one
solution it's a unique solution right so
so we had to get this um okay so this
makes uh
this makes sense it's strange especially
if you're used to the scalar setting
it's strange but makes sense
now you know naturally there's a concept
of right inverse
and so that says this a matrix x that
satisfies ax
equals i so here x appears on the right
that's why it's called the right inverse
that's called a right inverse of a and
if
if you have a right inverse you say the
matrix is right invertible
um and it turns out that
you can we can easily i mean we could
work this out separately but in fact
it's closely related left and right by
transpose and that makes sense because
when you transpose a matrix
um you first of all you reverse the
order of a matrix product and you turn
rows into columns and so on
so it turns out a is right invertible if
and only if a transpose is left
invertible
so in other words if you have ax equals
i that means x is a right inverse of a
if we transpose both sides of this
equation
we get ax transpose on the left and i
transpose but i transpose is i
i is a symmetric matrix meaning that
when you transpose it you get the same
matrix again
now we're going to use the transpose of
product rule it says that ax
transposes x transpose a transpose and
now we look at this and we go cool
x is a right inverse of a if and only if
x transpose is a left inverse of a
transpose
okay and so what that means is
a is right invertible if and only if the
columns of a transpose are linearly
independent
the columns of a transpose are the rows
of a so it says
a is right invertible if and only if its
rows
are linearly independent and that tells
us that
if a matrix is right invertible it must
be either wide
or square okay
now you can also solve linear equations
with a right inverse
so suppose b has a has a right inverse
matrix b now consider
the square or underdetermined because a
in this case
has to be either tall has to be square
or wide sorry it has to be square or
wide
ax equals b that's underdetermined okay
then it turns out
x equals b capital b little b is a
solution
why because if you take x equals
capital b times little b you get a x is
a times capital b little b
we reassociate get a b a b is i because
a b is a right inverse of a you get i
times b
and that is b okay um so that says
that the in this case the equations ax
equals b
has a solution for any b um in fact
we'll see later it has many solutions
but it at least has a solution for every
possible b so let's look at an example
it's going to be the same matrices as
above so a remember is 3 by 2
and then b and c were two left inverses
of
of a and that tells us that
c transpose and b transpose are both
right inverses of a
transpose now we consider the
underdetermined equation a transpose x
equals 1
2. now a transpose is 2 by 3 and that
says
this is a system of two equations with
three unknowns
um and when i multiply by b transpose
the right hand side
here um that's the right hand side if i
multiply that by both b
transpose and c transpose i get a
solution but here's what's kind of
interesting in this case i get
this vector and i get this vector and
you think oh
this doesn't look good but in fact you
can check that if i multiply this by a
transpose
i will get 1 2. if i multiply this by a
transpose i get 1 2.
so this is a case where this the these
two different right inverses actually
produce
two different solutions of the
undetermined system of equations
what we do now is tie this together into
what's basically the
usual that's the more usual case it's
the simple case
um and that's when you just have an
inverse
so let's see what that is now
um if a has a left and right inverse
they are unique
and equal okay so in other words
if a a has to be square of course in
that case because it has to be tall
to have a left inverse and it has to be
wide to have a right inverse
so if it has a left inverse and a right
inverse it's got to be
square square is allowed in both cases
so if a matrix has both the left and
right is
then it turns out they're they're the
same and and they're equal and there's
and there's only one inverse
so we're sort of back to the old
situation of a number right if a number
a is non-zero there is an inverse it's
called one over a
and it's unique they're not two numbers
that you can multiply by a and get one
okay now let's let me let me explain how
these are
they're actually the same so here
suppose that x is a right inverse of a
that's this equation and y is a y is a
left inverse
and what i'm going to show is in fact x
is equal to y
let's see how we check that well we
write well x is equal to i
x well we totally agree with that
because the identity multiplied by
if it multiplies the matrix either on
the left or right you get the matrix
back
and now i'm going to write i as y a
right because y a equals i and then i'll
reassociate and i write this as y
times ax oh but wait a minute a
x is i over here right so ax is i
and that says that's y i and that's y so
if you put all this chain together you
get x
equals y so that says that if a matrix
which has to be square of course
if it has both a left inverse and a
right inverse they're the same
there's no there's no difference between
left and right inverse
that's getting us it's more comfortable
right it's more like the situation with
a number where you say if i have a
number if it's non-zero
then x equals little x equals one over a
is the inverse and someone would say
left or right inverse and you go well it
doesn't matter they're numbers
if you multiply one over a times a you
get one it's the same as saying you
multiply a times one over a you get one
um but for matrices it's a little more
subtle but something similar to that is
occurring here it says that
if if you have an inverse like this um
then um that then it's unique right it's
both a left inverse and a right interest
okay
now they're denoted as a uh a inverse
right a
the minus one power right and that's
very similar to
um similar to how we we work with
numbers i mean it's weird to write you
know people don't
usually write two to the minus one well
they might actually
um and it's basically a half right so
so it's the inverse it's written as a
inverse
and what we've seen here is that an
inverse uh when multiplied by a matrix
when the inverse exists we'll get to
that later but
when the inverse exists uh it you can
multiply it on the left by a
or on the right and these these are in
general when you multiply two matrices
in different orders you get different
matrices in this case you don't
you get the same matrix since the
identity
and you can also check pretty easily
that a that the inverse of the inverse
is back to the matrix again and that
makes sense right i mean
in fact when you talk about inverting
something uh it's got that feeling that
if you do it twice
you get back the same thing it's like a
transpose if i transpose a matrix twice
i get the matrix back in this case if i
invert it twice assuming it is
invertible
then i get the matrix back right um the
previous example with transpose
uh has no conditions on it right so at
any matrix i can transpose and i
transpose twice i get back the original
matrix okay
so this is the matrix inverse
now we can use that to solve square
systems of linear
equations so let's suppose a is
invertible
and let's look at the cis square system
of linear equations
ax equals b then it says that for any b
it has ax equals b has only one solution
and that solution is simply a inverse b
okay and you know this is this is
basically the matrix generalization
of the scalar equation a x equals b
having the solution x equals one over a
b
and that's for a not equal to zero right
so
here uh invertible is going to play the
role of a not
being equal to zero not for a scalar
right so
that's the idea and this simple looking
formula x equals a inverse b
that's the basis for tons of
applications like uh
it could even be there's many there's
many applications
widely used where all it does
from a scientific point of view is a
sample a set of equations ax equals b
and then solve it for you by forming x
equals a inverse b
now we haven't said how to do that yet
but we will shortly um
so tons of things like that like if i
have a
a steel structure or some civil
engineering structure
and i want to find out will it be able
to handle the loads
that i'm going to put on a wind load uh
static loads that are inside a bridge or
something like doesn't matter and i want
to know how how much is it going to
deflect
um is it going to deflect too much
that's a set of linear equations
it's a x equals b and you simply
assemble these and then solve that
and that tells you your deflection
that's a simulator for trying to figure
out if i built this bridge will it sag
too much or something like that
okay so that that's that's the idea so
this is super important it's super
natural you have to watch out though
because
um this is very heavily uh
it's it's it's very powerful notation
right that that
this looks very innocent right you go
from a x equals b to x equals a inverse
b and you're like well sure why not
um just this this holds a lot this
a very small number of characters is
actually telling you a whole lot this is
very complicated
okay now for an invertible matrix
um there's a lot of way to say is that
the same i mean there's a lot of things
equivalent to being invertible and i'm
going to list them here
so if i have a square matrix say oh i
should say if a matrix is not square
game over cannot be invertible right
because if it's tall it can't have a
right inverse
okay if it's wide it can't have a left
inverse
and if you're invertible you have to
have both a left and a right inverse so
if your non-square matrix in fact i'll
mention that now
if you write a inverse ever and a
is not square that's a crime okay that's
that's what we call a crime against
matrices
it's don't do that right and the reason
it's a crime is because
you just it doesn't make any sense you
can check it uh you can check so easily
that the matrix a is square
now of course a square matrix need not
have an inverse like the 0 matrix
square 0 matrix 5 by 5 doesn't have an
inverse
but it's even worse just to assert that
a 3 by 5 matrix has an inverse right
because that's so easily checked by
essentially the syntax
the dimensions of a okay
so here are some these are completely
equivalent meaning if any one of these
holds then all the others do so one is
is invertible
we define that to mean it has a left
inverse and a right inverse
it's the same as saying the columns of
are linearly independent
which well we we saw one part of it
we'll see the other part later in the
course
that's the same as saying that a has a
left inverse right
um but it's also the same as saying the
rows of are linearly independent and
that's the same as a having a right
inverse
right so but the point is that any one
of these
is enough to tell you that all the
others
hold so for example for a square matrix
if the columns are linearly independent
then so are the rows um
i mean some of these are some are easy
right um
like here uh a is invertible implies
by definition the definition is it has
both a left inverse and a right inverse
so the fact that if a that this implies
these two is clear
what's less clear is this it says that
if a square matrix has a left inverse
it's also got a right inverse that's
what it says if
a has a right inverse it's got a left
inverse in fact it's the same matrix
right because
an inverse is unique okay
let's look at some examples of matrix
inverses um and i should say something
about this um
you should know a couple of these if
it's super duper easy you should you
should know it um
and you know i think people should know
you should probably memorize the formula
for the
two by two matrix inverse beyond that i
don't recommend it right it's what we
have computers for
right so um i'll just say that
so so but let's look at a couple just to
make sure it makes sense
so the versus says that the inverse of
the identity is
well the identity um so
that makes sense i mean and we can check
i mean i don't know let's see
so does does i have uh independent
columns
yeah it's the it's the it's just the
unit unit basis
uh uh let's see this is the standard
basis let's see uh
is um what is the inverse of i well it's
i and that
the reason is i times i equals i which
is true
okay um now if a matrix q is orthogonal
now um that means uh it's squared
uh with q transpose q equals i now
remember what that means
q transpose q equals i is basically very
compact matrix notation saying that the
columns of
q are linearly independent that's what q
transpose q equals i means
in that case i mean just look at this
equation right here's a matrix q
transpose
i multiply q on the left and i get the
identity
well it's square and so that says q
transfer is a left identity
a left inverse but that says because the
square is just the inverse so that says
that for example
q inverse equals q transpose so so for
and for an orthogonal matrix it says
that the
uh inverse is nothing but the transpose
they're the same thing
um notice that this also this actually
has an implication this also
says that in this case q q transpose
equals i
um which is not totally obvious by the
way
right so it says that uh this one
is the definition of the columns being
uh
of the columns being orthonormal right
uh this is less
obvious okay so for a two by two matrix
i mean you can just you can just work it
out and write it out and do a bunch of
algebra and stuff like that
and the truth is you may have seen this
before so uh it turns out there and i
i would recommend you just memorize this
although
on the other hand it's not clear to me
that you would come to any harm
if you didn't memorize it so actually
maybe let me let me put it another way
my my my my my feeling on this is
you should you should definitely know
that there is a formula for the matrix
inver for the
for a two by two make but the truth is a
formula for the inverse of any matrix is
just they get
huge and gigantic very quickly but for
two by two there's a formula
and maybe that's what you should
remember and this is like what wikipedia
is for
okay so you just look up two by inverse
of two by two matrix
okay so here it is it turns out the
condition
is there is a condition it has to hold
because otherwise you know we know that
not all two by two matrices are
invertible for example the zero matrix
is not invertible
and it basically says that the two
columns have to be linearly independent
that just means that the second column
cannot be a multiple of the first column
or vice versa
you can work out what that is and it's
this it's this thing it says that the
product of the diagonals
uh cannot equal the product of the i
guess people call these the
anti-diagonals the
the 1 2 and the 2 1 entry
now some of you may have seen from
another course you'd recognize
this number as the determinant of a
matrix a
determinant doesn't really play a
leading role in what we're going to say
doesn't matter i mean but if you just if
you've seen that then
good for you uh but it's not going to
play a role in this in this course
and here's the inverse i mean it's a bit
strange it's it's one over this mystery
number it's the determinant
times here i mean the rule is uh you you
switch a
you know the 1 1 and 2 2 entry and you
negate the off diagonal entries so
that's it
and yeah i would say you should know
this formula it's kind of like the
quadratic formula for
you know what are the roots of a
quadratic yeah i guess it's on a it's on
a short list of
i don't know 10 silly things you should
you know
little basic facts that you should know
um okay
now uh for larger uh
matrices like three by three four by
four five by five
there are formulas that look just like
this but they are fantastically
complicated
um so i think even if you were to write
out the formula for the 10 by 10 inverse
i don't even think you could
i mean it's impossible right and the
reason is that the complexity of the
formulas kind of grows like the
factorial
of n and 10 factorial is a pretty big
number
so so while there's a formula for a 10
by 10 inverse it's
you can't write it it's it's not
practical to write it down
and i should also add that that formula
is absolutely
not the way you solve or compute an
inverse
right so we'll shortly see the in fact
the truth is the hilarious part is you
already know how to compute an inverse
we just haven't gotten there yet um so
but the point is that
that method is completely
straightforward it doesn't grow like the
factorial or something like that but
anyway
okay but here it is uh it's a two by two
inverse
and you know you can check it i mean
multiply this by
take this matrix here multiply it by you
know a
and make sure that you get i i would
recommend doing that
okay so let's look at a non-obvious
example um
here's a matrix a um oh and we should
talk about something
um let's talk about first let's talk
about invertibility of numbers
okay well anybody can recognize that
because it's simple
if the number is not zero it's
invertible period so
it's not a big deal to figure out if i
show you a number if it's invertible or
not it the only question is this is zero
okay now for matrices that's false okay
unless it's two by two in which case
here's the condition
right um but um for a bigger matrix than
that
uh no human being can just look at a
general matrix and go
yeah that's invertible oh yeah no
problem sure that's that's
that's invertible or or not
well there would be some obvious
giveaways in some very simple cases but
generally no
i don't know if it's invertible or not
okay now
this matrix turns out is invertible and
here's the inverse
it's it's 1 30 times this matrix here
and you can
you can just check uh check me on that
that that works out
um i mean if you like let's audit one
entry uh
you know why not so let's let's multiply
let's say a inverse times a and let's
calculate the 1 1 entry
well i'm going to go across here and
down
here and here's what i'm going to get
i'm going to get
0 times 1
which is 0 minus 20 times 0 and the last
one
is minus 10 times -3 which is 30. then i
divide by 30 out here and i get 1.
okay good so the the 1-1 entry of a
inverse a
is indeed one which is correct it's the
identity matrix
okay so um now how do you find the
inverse
we're going to tell you later it's it's
super duper simple
it's not like i just want to be weird or
anything and not tell you yet you'll see
soon enough that it it comes up and how
to compute it
but for now um we're just saying you
know this is an example of
a matrix that's invertible
okay now in the inverse process
um involves uh you know there's a bunch
of properties that that hold for example
the product of two matrices um and then
quantity inverse is b inverse a inverse
now
this equation um this this is
all the inverses here have to have to
exist right so
a b has to have an inverse b has to have
an inverse
a has to have an inverse okay so
but provided that happens then this is
the same thing so
inverse is like transpose in other words
that when you apply it to a matrix
matrix product it's the same as applying
the operation
to the individual matrices in the
reverse order right so
uh that's how that works um transpose
and
inverse so a transpose inverse is equal
to a inverse transpose
and then some people actually write that
a to the minus
a minus transpose so um
so that's how they that that some people
would write it that way you would see
that in papers and books and things like
that
okay um now we can also talk now that we
have
remember that we we if we had a square
matrix we
we know what a is we know what a squared
is and we know what a cubed is
and so on right we decided that a to the
is i and now we have assigned a meaning
to a
inverse well we can also have a meaning
now for a to the minus two
uh and that's going to be a inverse
squared and so on
so though now we can now we can talk
about the powers
positive or negative of a matrix that's
square
and invertible if it's not invertible
but just square we can talk about its
zeroth
power first power second power and so on
okay
now with this definition of these
inverses you get this beautiful thing
that holds for numbers as well it says
that
a matrix to the k times a matrix to the
l gives you a to the k
plus l so the exponents add when you
take a product
um and that holds even if k and l are
negative positive
doesn't matter okay so that's kind of
the it's a pretty
it's a pretty picture and this is this
is one case where the formula or a
formula
for numbers uh actually holds
four matrices right so that it
generalizes but you have to be very
much on your very much on your toes
because some things don't
all right so we're going to talk about
triangular matrices
for a good for a particular reason um
triangular matrices they come up a whole
in a lot of applications actually we
already saw one
we saw one in the so-called qr
factorization when
you run gram-schmidt you factor a matrix
a
into a matrix q and a matrix r which is
upper triangular so
so we've already seen triangular
matrices okay so here it is
um a matrix is called lower triangular
um if it what it means is
it means this uh so it means that here's
here's the matrix it's got to be square
and it says you can have stuff you can
have non-zero things on the diagonal
here
so on the on the diagonal and everything
down here
is potentially allowed to be non-zero
but it has to be zero in the upper
triangle
so that's what it needs to be lower
triangular um
and the claim is this if you have a
lower triangular matrix
with non-zero diagonal entries it's
invertible
okay now we have to show that
um now the way we're going to show it is
to show that the columns of x
are i'm sorry the columns of l are
linearly independent that's how we're
going to show that
um and to do that what we're going to do
is we're going to we're going to
actually write down lx equals 0
and end up with the following conclusion
x equals 0.
that's the same as showing the columns
of l are independent because lx equals 0
means
a linear combination of the columns of l
are 0 with coefficients x and we want to
show the only coefficients that do that
are x equals 0. that's that's what we
want to do
okay so we write down the equations this
way this is this is now written out
and let's take a look at it
well actually it's the first equation is
fine
because that's just a product of two
numbers l one one times x one is zero
but we're assuming l one one is non-zero
so x one is zero
that's awesome because it means you see
this first column it just goes away
they're all zero
let's look if you look at the second
equation here it says that l2 1x1 plus
altitude x2 is 0. but wait a minute
x1 is 0. we know we already figured that
out so this says l2 x2 equals 0.
x2 has got to be 0 because l2 is
non-zero okay
and you keep going uh and what this
shows is that
the only way if you have lx equals zero
that can happen is x equals zero that
says the columns of l are linearly
independent
and that says that l is invertible it's
got an inverse
okay now same thing for upper
triangular r uh with a non-zero diagonal
edge the same because it's the transpose
of a lower triangular matrix
okay so triangular matrices with
non-zero
entries on the diagonal are invertible
by the way a triangular matrix
with a zero on the diagonal is
non-invertible
okay now we can get the inverse and sure
enough it's going to be the one
algorithm that we already looked at
in fact it's pretty much the only
algorithm we're going to use in the
course is the qr factorization
or gram schmidt okay so suppose a
is square and invertible that means
these columns are linearly independent
that means if we run gram schmidt it
will run to completion
and that says we'll end up with a
factorization and it's going to look
like a
equals q r uh that's why it's called the
qr factorization
q is orthogonal right its columns are
orthogonal
and that means that q transpose q equals
i if q is square
okay and r is upper triangular with
positive diagonal entries
if you remember the diagonal entries
were the norms of something like the
norms of the q
tildes or something like that which was
an intermediary before
being in the gram-schmidt algorithm
before being normalized and the point is
they're non-zero
um and so it's it's invertible okay and
that says
this now it's going to get you know it
says a inverse is
a is qr inverse of that both q and
r are invertible we know that in fact
it's r inverse is the first one and q
inverse
but q is orthogonal it satisfies this
and so that says
its inverse is its transpose so here it
is it's r inverse
q transpose there you go so so
uh this says we can get um
the inverse via qr factorization
actually i haven't yet quite said how to
get our inverse
but that's coming we're going to get
that in just a minute